>> Juan: IT COULD BE ANOTHER
CONTROVERSIAL WEEKEND FOR OUR
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT HEADING TO A BIG
COLLEGE FOOTBALL GAME BETWEEN
ALABAMA AND LSU.
THE CRIMSON TIDE ORIGINALLY SAID
STUDENTS WILL BE PUNISHED FOR
BOOING.
AFTER OUTRAGE, AND NFL LEGEND
TERRY BRADSHAW WEIGHING IN.
>> YOU HAVE TO SIMPLY RESPECT
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES.
IT'S REALLY RIGHT, IT'S REALLY
LEFT, IT'S ANGRY AND IT'S
HOSTILE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Juan: EMILY, YOU CAN'T STOP
STUDENTS FROM BOOING.
>> Emily: YOU DON'T LIKE
THAT'S THE POINT.
THE STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT CAME
OUT AND SAID, YOU DON'T BREW.
THE SCHOOL CAME OUT AND SAID,
YOU HAVE TO ABIDE BY THE
CAPSTONE CREATED, ESSENTIALLY,
NO CONDUCT UNBECOMING OF A
STUDENT, AND OF COURSE YOU CAN
EXERCISE YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
SILENCE SPEAKS VOLUMES THAT I
WAS RAISED IN RAIDER NATION.
I KNOW HOW TO SHOUT THINGS.
IF A PRESIDENT I DIDN'T AGREE
WITH CAME, I WOULDN'T TELL ME I
WOULD STAND NO MATTER WHAT.
BUT ON THE CHAIR.
JUST DO THAT.
>> Juan: YOU'VE GOT TO CLOSE
SCHOOLS IN RED STATES, ALABAMA
AND LOUISIANA STATE UNIVERSITY.
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE A LOT OF
WORRY.
TRUMP SHOULD BE GETTING A GOOD
RECEPTION.
IS THIS A SIGN OF SOME PROBLEM?
>> Jesse: HE'S NOT GOING TO
GET BOOED AT ALL.
THERE IS GOING TO AN
OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF APPLAUSE.
THIS IS THE DEEP SOUTH, THIS IS
MAGA COUNTRY, THE STUDENT
SECTION IS MAGA COUNTRY FOR THE
INITIAL THING IS DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR, WHICH IS NO STREAKING.
DON'T DO ANYTHING CRAZY TO
DISRUPT THE SCHOOL.
>> Juan: DID YOU HEAR THIS?
JESSE WANTS STREAKING.
>> Dana: I WANT SOME DRAMA.
>> Juan: ARE YOU GOING TO
WATCH THE GAME?
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK JOE IS
GOING HAVE A GOOD GAME?
>> Dana: WHO?
I THINK GO TIGERS, BUT DON'T GET
MAD AT ME IF YOU ARE FROM
ALABAMA.
THE PRESIDENT IS EXERCISING
EXCELLENT POLITICAL JUDGMENT BUT
ALSO IT'S THE BENEFIT OF
INCUMBENCY.
HE'S GOING TO GO TO THE GAME.
IT'S LIKE WHEN OBAMA WENT TO THE
NCAA TOURNAMENT.
IT'S LIKE, OH, THAT'S SO COOL.
HE GETS TO GO.
IF YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT CAN YOU
GET TO GO.
I WOULD DEFTLY GO.
ALSO, DON'T FORGET, THERE IS A
GOVERNOR'S RACE IN LOUISIANA AND
THAT ELECTION IS NEXT SATURDAY.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT THIS
WEEK TO DO A RALLY TO TRY TO
HELP THAT REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
TO BEAT THE INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT.
THAT'S A VERY CLOSE RACE.
I DON'T KNOW IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN HERE BUT DOESN'T HURT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO THIS GAME.
>> Juan: DIDN'T HELP IN
KENTUCKY, DID IT?
>> Dana: NOT FOR THAT
PARTICULAR RACE BUT ALL THE
OTHER ONES, IT DID.
>> Juan: GREG, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT BOOING?
YOU LIKE TO BOOT
GRADE:
>> Greg: I'M PRO BOOING, I AM
PRO-CHEERING.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BOOING AND
NOT BOMBING.
YOU CAN'T SPELL STOCK MARKET
BOOM WITHOUT BOO.
CNN IS COUNTING THE AMOUNT OF
TIMES THAT DONALD TRUMP SAYS A
SPECIFIC WORD.
THEY COUNT IT 34 TIMES, THE
EXPERT ON THE ACCOUNT THAT HE
SAID THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS
INACCURATE 34 TIMES PER THEY
HAVE PEOPLE DOING THAT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY NEWS TO
REPORT.
THEY GO AFTER MISSPELLINGS -- WE
ARE IN A GREAT AGE WHERE WE'LL
LOOK 30 YEARS AND GO, MAN, WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WHEN
PRESIDENT KANYE WEST COMES IN.
>> Juan: DON'T GET AHEAD OF
IT...
YOU DON'T THINK IT'S AS ANYTHING
BUT HIS WEAKNESS THAT PEOPLE IN